you should definitely be sampling both
sides of the news if you're not looking
at Fox News and CNN you don't know
what's happening so if you're trapped in
your bubble and it's becoming a
self-fulfilling prophecy what's the
first step to breaking out of your loser
thing well it's good to know what all
the various parts of loser think are and
I go through them like don't be a mind
reader don't predict the future with
analogies history doesn't predict
slippery slope isn't real yeah fairly
well I want to go through a few it yeah
so without details so it's good to know
what those are but beyond that you
should definitely be sampling both sides
of the news if you're not looking at Fox
News and CNN you don't know what's
happening because I've tried doing that
try to pick a topic and before you've
heard what the other says just consume
one silo and then you go to the other
one you're like wow I didn't know
anybody was saying this are you telling
me these facts are real and it doesn't
matter which way you're going they're
completely different but is it almost
impossible to break out of that I mean
we all talk about this all the time
we're catering news to ourselves the
algorithms are feeding us things that
you know reinforce our thoughts already
but is it almost impossible to break out
of it because in a weird way
psychologically we don't want to break
out of it I know some people do but that
most of us kind of we just you know not
sound corny wheat that's the safe space
we find and good and we're reinforced
and it's warm this is why I sort of
sneak in the back door if I said to you
Dave I'm gonna get you to change teams
whatever your team is Democrat
Republican doesn't matter you would
immediately say or you know you'd be
like it everything you're shooting at me
is bouncing off my force field but if I
say here's how you should think in the
you know in any situation you want to
have something to compare something to a
very simple statement people accept that
because that's just you know reasonable
on its surface and then you take that
through all right now apply this to your
thinking so you can sometimes get people
to talk themselves out of their position
by giving them better tools but you
can't just say change teams because
you're on the wrong team how much is
this do you think is just base human
psychology just sort of the stuff we're
born with that certain people are just
sort of more progra
to go to just things that reinforce
their beliefs and some people are just
programmed to actually being a little
bit more open well I think all of these
things have a you know you're born with
a certain set of gifts and intelligence
etc but in looser think I talked about
how you the experience you've had across
domains is what gives you better vision
so for example if you'd never been
exposed to economics I've got a degree
in economics you wouldn't know how
economists think so you might run into a
concept like a sunk cost and if you'd
never been exposed to this you might say
well I have common sense and people
would say we've already spent all this
money so we better keep investing
because I don't want to waste that money
I already spent that's not sensible an
economists would say no the money that's
gone should not influence your next
decision because it's gone now the first
time you hear that you say oh yeah like
you don't need to read a book on it you
just hear it and so I tried to make it
as simple as that you just got to hear
it once and they say yeah that makes
sense yeah so you don't think so you
think we all have sort of pre-programmed
abilities to be flexible on some of
these things but but you think that that
can pretty much always be different
local sue yeah yeah I mean people are
more or less locked in more or less team
players more or less capable of you know
looking at details and thinking properly
but everybody can do it better yeah do
you think the Internet's changing that
just relative to the speed that we get
information and the fact that you can
now go out there and find roughly a
gajillion voices in two minutes that
might be able to help break some of your
stuff I'll tell you the biggest problem
I think and this is brand new thought is
that we are as humans were copiers were
imitators so if you wade into the
internet what kind of thinking style are
you going to see the worst and people
will imitate it so they'll say for
example hey your site did X and what's
the most common response your site did
actually yeah what did that help
they helped nothing that wasn't even on
the topic you didn't even talk about
your time if they're going to do it we
have to do it right so some of it is of
course power and influence and
persuasion and all that
nobody's trying to think so you have to
you have to be able to weed out okay was
anybody even trying or were they just
persuading yeah do you think most of us
just don't want to try them at some
level I mean most people just kind of
they don't want to think about things
that seriously because that brings up a
lot of deep existential sighs maybe you
know maybe maybe there are lots of
reasons we don't want to be wrong we
don't like to be embarrassed we don't
like to change your mind we don't want
to disappoint the team and we're
influenced by what we see so we just
join in and say well that's what my team
is doing I guess I'll do some of that so
you talk about some of the dumb ideas
that are floating around so that thus
create our own bubbles so I wanted to go
through a couple of them because we hear
these all the time and they sort of
sound right but you don't quite think
they are right we know when history will
repeat itself and when it won't we hear
this all the time history repeats
yes history repeats itself and and
because it has a phrase and we've heard
the phrase we give it wait because the
brain will say well it's a saying it's
not pretty sure I've seen that on a
bumper sticker so there must be
something about that but it's an
illusion caused by the fact that we
don't notice when history doesn't repeat
which is most of the time why is it the
history doesn't repeat because it can't
there's never two situations that are
same the variables have changed and if
nothing else has changed
you saw what and what went wrong the
last time so you fix it this time so
it's a complete illusion that we can
predict the future because this time is
like that last time the most you can do
is say people are still selfish stupid
at all those things so if you put it in
a situation where they can steal well
sure they'll steal you know not
everybody but if you have enough people
introduced to a situation where you can
steal something somebody's gonna take a
run at it but that's not really history
repeating right so you would say a
better way to say it would be something
like themes repeat themselves just
because they because it's based in our
nature not the specific event I would
even make a smaller than that I would
say people are people so we you know
they're gonna be selfish and all the
qualities of people so any situation you
put it and put them in you should say
well let's look at cause and effect if I
put that person where the free money is
well you know I should expect money to
be taken but not because history repeats
it's just a simple cause and effect so
if it doesn't repeat itself what would
you say to all the history majors right
now that are listening to this well
here's what would be the point of being
a historian if not to have some sort of
roadmap for the future right well indeed
the history is what prevents it from
repeating in some sense because you know
what didn't work so you might see
history repeat when it works so if
something worked before you might see
somebody try to try it again but even
you take anything like North Korea all
right what was the main thing people
said when President Trump got elected
was while talking to North Korea will
never work or blah and maybe it won't
but he got it further than anybody else
he got it into a personal level it
wasn't anything like history so no
matter how many times history had
repeated you introduced this whole new
variable the president Trump and then
history doesn't count anymore what do
you make of that concept that people who
said one thing two years ago say the
complete opposite and I don't mean that
they flipped all their beliefs but that
it's always a team thing you know it's
like if Obama had talked to God North
Korea talked to Kim Jong and they you
know a certain set of people the
Republicans in this case would have been
like he's crazy we can't talk with these
people
Trump does it we can do it you can flip
that the other way I mean that that I
guess that goes what you're saying about
the team thing but do you think people
realize the sort of absurdity I'm not
talking about evolving over a period of
time with certain set of opinions I'm
talking that because the players are
different that you just completely taken
opposite yeah one of the great mysteries
as you watch somebody who doesn't agree
with you and they're doing that crazy
thinking like you mentioning and you
watch them and you think yourself is
that real do they really think that yeah
and I spend time doing that too but one
of the advantages I have is having
studied hypnosis
I understand people to be irrational
most of the time and I understand them
to be rationalize errs and I understand
confirmation bias and cognitive
dissonance so my take is that most of
the time they actually believe what
they're saying and because they can't
see it you know they're the ones who are
blinded to it so it look looks like it
makes sense to them do you think there's
some reason like an obvious or
psychological reason that the people who
seem most obsessed by politics on a
day-to-day basis and I'm not talking
about like sort of the broad theme stuff
but as you said before you you're really
sort of uninterested in politics but the
people that are obsessed with you know
the nitty gritty excuse me the nitty
gritty what happened today what happened
tomorrow kind of or what's happening
tomorrow there's a reason that they're
so miserable because it's it's sort of
been like it's like an untenable system
that they're playing with all the time
well you know people are different so
it's probably all different reasons I do
it for entertainment and I think other
people are drawn in from the fight you
know they're like the fight so what's my
fight today oh there's a new headline
let me get into that fight there's
definitely a dopamine or serotonin hit
that people get just from making a good
points like I got that guy said
something bad about this celebrity got
him some type it was a real fight like
involving weapons they would be much
more reserved what do you think I know I
would yeah exactly if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell